members of President Trump's own party
are now trying to distance themselves
from the presidentials from the
president's rather controversial remarks
about a far-right group in Tuesday
night's chaotic debate we all remember
that the president created an outcry by
not condemning groups like The Proud
boys which has engaged in violent acts
and whose supporters have often backed
white supremist ideas the committee in
charge of these debates made it very
clear yesterday that the next one will
be very different for one thing the
candidates who interrupt may be cut off
Paula Reed is at the White House with
the president's effort to step back to
step back rather from the white
supremacy controversy so Paula what is
the president's strategy now everybody's
watching Everybody is watching good
morning Gail well amid this backlash
from his own party last night the
president returned to the campaign Trail
and at a rally in Minnesota a state the
campaign thinks it could win the
president bragged to adoring supporters
about the debate's readings and his
performance even as some of his top
advisers believe that his chaotic debate
style was really a missed opportunity to
potentially allow his Democratic rival
to make a gaff or commit to policy
positions he might eventually come to
regret I held Joe Biden accountable for
his 47 years of Lies 47 years of
betrayal and 47 years of failure
president Trump continued to slam his
Democratic rival former Vice President
Joe Biden as he campaigned in Minnesota
Wednesday night you know Biden lost
badly when his supporters are saying he
should cancel the rest of the debates
but as he left the White House earlier
in the day the president tried to clean
up his much criticized comment on white
supremacy and the group proud boys
during the first presidential debate
they're going to stand down they have to
stand down everybody they have to stand
whatever group you're talking about let
law enforcement do the work it was a
step further than he had gone on Tuesday
when asked to denounce white supremacist
groups
and stand back and stand by many
republican lawmakers felt stand back and
standby was inadequate should the
president have more forcefully denounced
white
supremacists yeah he should have been
very clear the president claimed he
didn't know the group I don't know who
the proud boys are but the proud boys
embraced his comments as a call to Arms
I've always denounced any form any form
any form form of any of that you have to
denounce president Trump has repeatedly
refused to denounce far-right extremism
which the FBI says is one of the most
serious threats facing the nation he
said this after white supremacist groups
descended on Charlottesville in 2017 I
think there's blame on both sides you
look at you look at both sides I think
there's blame on both sides I think was
just a a national embarrassment on a
train tour across Ohio and Pennsylvania
Democratic candidate Joe Biden seized on
the comments I just tell him to stand
down but stand
by go
online the proud boys now have a
logo saying stand down but stand by we
need to remember who in God's name we
are this is the United States of
America the proud boys put out a
statement last night saying they condemn
all forms of isms whether it's racism
fascism communism or socialism now
following that contentious and chaotic
debate the commission that runs these
debates they say they're going to make
some changes to the format at the top of
their list is going to be the ability to
control the candidates mics so they
can't interrupt each other or the
moderators Tony well I'll take it thank
you